Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This will be my last of us Season
2 video.
They've already explained
what's happening with the season.
They're changing it dramatically
from the plot of the Last of Us to game.
So we'll explain why they're changing it,
how they're changing it.
Of course, I'll be doing videos for season
two episodes, just like I did
for season one,
so be sure to subscribe to get everything
and careful for spoilers
for the Season one episodes.
If you haven't seen the finale yet,
the only thing we can be sure of
is that we understand why he did it
and we understand that
Ellie would not have wanted him to do it.
So the big news is that Neil Druckmann
and the showrunner HBO just in general
have said that they do plan
on doing a completely different
storyline than the last of Us to game,
or at least at the beginning.
Originally,
they'd also said that they were going
to split the story of the second game
into multiple future seasons.
So in the way that they changed
some of the storyline for the first game
for season one, they'll do that
even more during season 2.
Part of the reason
why they're splitting the story
into multiple seasons,
they didn't do that during season one
is because the story of the first game
is so much shorter
than the story of the second game.
People who hated
the second game will be really happy
to know that they are changing the plot
dramatically
for a couple of different reasons.
One of the big things about the second
game is also that it was very divisive
with the fan base, so people either
loved it or they absolutely hated it.
So have you seen a lot of talk
online like, oh, people
love season one,
but they're going to hate season 2
because they've been expecting season
two to directly adapt the exact same plot
as the second video game.
That's why because it was so much blowback
in the fandom for the second game,
and largely it's
because the game takes a dramatic left
turn and really only follows
the lead character.
So it just feels like complete
different vibe,
like a totally different type of game,
different story
than what people were expecting
after the events of the first game.
Like, wait a minute,
this is a story about Joe and Ellie
having adventures in is very likely
that HBO just does not want to completely
turn the show on Bella Ramsey.
She did a great job as Ellie
during season one, but I don't think that
she could hold up an entire show for
like another 3 to 4 seasons by herself.
Pedro Pascal is on fire right now.
If you haven't been watching
My Mandalorian Season
three episode videos, he is fantastic in
pretty much everything that he does.
We are full Pedro Pascal
into the Pascal verse right now with him
just blowing it up all over the place.
The funny thing about that too,
is that the plot of The Mandalorian
is very similar
to the plot of The Last of Us, with him
protecting Grogu you on The Mandalorian
and protecting Ellie.
He's like a protective dad on both series
protecting children.
So when they see
the dramatically changing the plot
of the second game for season 2,
what they might be doing
is using a lot of the flashbacks
in the missing period during a time jump
between season one and season 2,
that the game just skips completely
over the events of the second game
pick up after a five year time jump
after the end of season one.
In the end of season
one ends pretty much where you saw
the end of the finale with them
looking out over time, the settlement,
the promise,
the lie that Joe tells to Ellie again
if they still plan on adapting
most of the characters
from the second game, they can use that
five year time jump to tell more story,
more development of Ellie, and develop
Abby's character,
who winds up being the main antagonist
of the second game.
There was actually a brief reference
to Abby in the finale,
but not the kind of Easter egg
that you would expect to see. Like she is.
A character did not appear in the finale,
but Laura Bailey, the voice actor
who played Abby in the games, did cameo
as one of the nurses in the finale.
In in the games.
Abby is meant to be
the daughter of the Fireflies lead surgeon
that Joel killed, setting up this revenge
arc for her character,
where she becomes
the main antagonist in the second game.
But this character
that Laura Bailey was playing,
which is meant to be a regular nurse,
it was just a bit of an Easter egg
behind the scenes that she herself
was the voice actor who played Abby.
I don't expect her to play Abby on the TV
show in Season 2.
Speaking of video game actors cameos
and big connections in other productions,
some of you might remember Laura Bailey
from Critical Role, which she also does
was Ashley Johnson, who cameoed as Ellie's
mother in the episode.
In What they can do
during season 2 is Tell More the story
during that missing five year time jump,
develop Abby's character and just delay
the meeting between Abby, Joel and Ellie
until much later in the games.
And without getting into big spoilers,
they can always say the big twist
with Joel and Abby's character
to the very end of the series,
like season four, Season five, they wanted
to however many seasons they want to go.
So that's probably what they mean
when they say they're going to radically
change the plot of the second game
for season 2, season three and beyond.
For those that complained about this,
they also confirmed that season
two will have way more infected
in different kinds of infected,
which is meant to be a reference
to the other stages
of the infection in types of infect
that you run into in the games.
Stage one are meant to be the runners
Stage two or the stalkers, after a little
bit of time has gone by, after more
time goes by, they develop into clickers.
And then the most powerful stage
that we saw was stage four, the blotters,
which we saw back in episode five
when they were teasing
the other types of infected.
They were talking mostly about Shamblers,
which are stage four,
which become more powerful
and harder to kill
and potentially stage five,
which is basically like the Rat King.
The ranking is meant to be this amalgam
of a bunch of different types of infected
that kind of morph together
and turn into a giant hybrid
infected
sort of like a transformer infected.
He's more like a boss level character,
so they probably save him for much.
Later in the series.
They said the main reason
why there weren't
as many infected during season one
that people were expecting
is mostly because they said
when they were writing the season, John
Elliott fight against the infected
in the game and those different parts
felt ancillary or to extra
for what was happening with the plot.
Well, they had a hard time justifying
a lot of those fights during the episodes,
like why would they go off and fight
this other group of infected for like
another 15 minutes of the episode
when it's not necessary?
So I think they heard a lot of fans
complaints like, wait a minute,
they're supposed to be infected, fungus
all over the place.
Why aren't we seeing more of that?
HBO said note taken way
more infected coming to season 2.
But during the five year time jump, it's
meant to be a period of relative
quiet safety
in which Joel nurtures and raises Ellie.
He pays off his reference earlier in the
finale by teaching her how to play guitar.
A lot of the songs that they play
are cover songs featured in both games,
which they also use during the Last of Us
Season one episodes.
During this time, Ellie keeps her immunity
secret from everyone
else, and time is community.
Tommy knows, but everybody else
doesn't know about it yet.
She even winds up
masking her bite mark with the tattoo,
but it's meant to be a good life.
Over those next five years.
After the end of season one, she makes
good friends like Deena and Jessie.
They add an Easter Egg
quick cameo scene for Dina.
Earlier, when they first visited
Tommy's settlement, fans spotted this
and Neil Druckmann kind of confirmed it.
He implied this girl peeking at Ellie,
who she yells at because her social skills
are non-existent at this point.
It's supposed to be DNA from later
in the games.
Both and Ellie spend a lot of time
just working the regular
odd jobs, helping protect the community
from random infected.
They show up in the area.
There are infected in fungus in the area.
There's not quite as many
as you would expect in a large city.
Joel continues to nurture his hobbies
like woodworking, wildlife,
guitar playing, trying to nurture Ellie's
interest like outer space dinosaurs.
But slowly, more and more of a wedge grows
between the two of them over Ellie's
perceived loss of her destiny.
Her grand purpose
for existing in the Season one finale.
She knows
deep down he's not telling the truth,
but she can't let herself believe it.
Too scary.
The idea that the only purpose in life
hasn't been fulfilled.
And then Joel puts all of that
on the line.
Like a parent, you feel like you need
to lie to your children to protect them.
And that's what Joel does at the very end
that that had been taken away
from her by the person that she loves
and trusts the most.
It's too overwhelming.
So she forces herself to believe Joe, and
she's assumed that whole time
during season one, she'd helped
the Fireflies save the entire human race.
And even during their initial escape,
she had started to suspect
everything that Joel told her about.
What happened wasn't totally true.
And slowly over time,
that feeling begins to fester in her
as she grows complacent and directionless
with no sense of real purpose anymore.
Like, what is she supposed to be doing?
What is life going to be?
Now that she doesn't
have a grand purpose anymore?
She starts to probe him
for more details and answers
until finally he admits
everything he told her was a lie.
And why he did it.
You find out the year
before the second game picks up about year
four into the time jump,
she went back to the Salt Lake City
Hospital, St Mary's Hospital herself
to get her own answers
about what happened and discovers
the truth.
Joel winds up telling her the whole truth
and it destroys their relationship.
Ellie There's
one of anything to do with them any more.
But Joel continues to watch over her,
still caring about her like a daughter,
and he still believes what he did
was best for her.
All the single dads out there, like
I believe in Joel, he did the right thing.
It's after this that you meet
the Abby Anderson
character in the Washington
Liberation Front, her group or the love.
They had traveled
800 miles from Seattle to find Joel
so that Abby could get revenge for him
killing her father,
the fireflies lead surgeon
that he killed in the finale
during a random winter storm
at Tommy's settlement.
A herd of infected attack in the chaos,
Joel and Tommy wind up helping Abby
without realizing who she is.
Putting the man that she was trying
to find right where she wanted him.
With Ellie, finding them too late
in having to witness what goes down,
and it winds up being this big revenge arc
for Ellie against Abby in her group.
So it's at this point that the W left
the Washington Liberation Front
in the Abby character become the main
villains of the second game
and is basically here
where the plot of the second game
just completely takes a left
turn direction where fans
just were completely flabbergasted
like wait a minute,
we were not expecting the game
to take this direction.
What's going on?
It is basically right
at the beginning of the second game,
like very little time goes by, then boom.
So this is why I'm saying
that HBO wants to change the plot
dramatically of the second game.
Like we don't want one episode
and then the show to completely
just follow Bella Ramsey by herself.
Thematically, though,
the whole second game is meant to be about
the trauma
of what Ellie is forced to witness
and how it consumes her
for the rest of the events of the games.
Probably the third game too.
If they make the Last of Us 3
putting her and Abby on parallel arcs,
it takes Ellie to a very dark place
in the way that Joel was
a very dark person
at the beginning of the first season,
and they try to use the story
of the second game to show you how revenge
often winds up destroying the very people
who are seeking it.
Like if you're seeking revenge,
dig two graves, one for the other person
and one for yourself.
But the leaders of this other group, the w
l, that will probably wind up becoming
one of the main antagonist of future
seasons are Isaac Dixon, Marcus Wilson.
Luis Sanchez.
Jason Emma Patterson in Isaac's story
is actually very similar to Kathleen
in The Hunters, in that he winds up
being kind of a tyrant that the W
of holds up as a really awesome person
that was able to get rid of Phaedra
because the w l f in the Seattle
quarantine zone
was successful, kind of like
the hunters were in getting rid of HYDRA.
Agents implied that the Isaac character
was every bit as stabby, every bit
as much of a tyrant as Kathleen was.
So they might do a season 2
in future seasons is just start earlier
in that five year time
gap between the first and the second game
to show more development,
show more of Ellie's relationship
with these other characters
like Jessie and Dina,
so that when they become bigger characters
later in the story, fans care about them
way more.
And so when the Abby character
shows up in the story,
people care about her way more, too.
And also,
when the plot starts turning more around,
Ellie versus Abby,
if they do go in that direction,
eventually fans will just care about it
more.
Won't feel like a knee jerk left turn.
Abby Kind of like on Game of Thrones
if you follow the Jon Snow character
and a lot of these are the main characters
for the first five seasons,
then he dies at the end of season five
and he doesn't come back in.
They follow the Little Bear character
and you're like,
Wait a minute, Why is the story
following the Little Bear now?
It feels like,
No, no, we're not going to do that.
They want to keep their Pedro
Pascal Joel character on the show
as long as possible.
The other path they might be taking
is they do pick up
after the five year time jump because
Bella Ramsay in real life is actually
about as old as
Ellie is in the second game.
It's just that she still
looks like a little girl.
Physically,
they could follow
the plot of the second game
very closely like they did during season
one in the first game, but they just don't
do the big Jo Abby Twist
and they leave that
for the very end of the series
so that during season 2,
season three, you spend all this time
traveling around with Ellie.
But Pedro Pascal is Jo is with her,
or they could substitute
someone else for that big Joel Twist
like Tommy's character,
and they could always do something
completely different with Abby playing
a totally different role in the narrative,
and she's not the main villain.
In Season 2,
they created the Kathleen character
out of whole cloth, out of nothing
for the show.
She wasn't part of the games.
They could do the same thing in season
two with the Washington Liberation Front,
or they could delay their group
and bring back the hunters as more revenge
villains in season 2
and replace some of the Abby storyline
with more Hunters revenge stuff.
Let me know
in the comments, though,
if HBO says they're going to radically
change the plot of the second game
for season
two in future seasons, what do you think
they're going to change about the plot?
I'll do More Last of Us season 2 videos.
When we get more details
and we start getting some footage
when they start filming in
Related HBO News House
of the Dragon Season
2 episodes will be releasing next year.
I just did The House of the Dragon Season
2 teaser videos all linked up
below in the description
and in related Pedro Pascal News
The Mandalorian season three Episodes
that Started My Full Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 3 Video
We'll post later this week.
You can click here for that,
update the link as soon as I post
that and click here for my full Last of Us
episode nine Finale Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.